checking your phone 96 times a day.
Look, that's once every 10 minutes
you're awake. And we wonder why we feel
anxious. Here's what nobody tells you.
Your phone is designed like a casino.
Those red notification badges, the
infinite scroll, it's all calculated
manipulation. But I discovered three
gamechanging tricks that gave me my life
back. First, grayscale mode. Instagram
and black and white hits different.
Suddenly, that infinite scroll loses all
its power. Second, the 80% battery rule.
Stop obsessing over 100%. You'll
actually use your phone without anxiety.
Third, turn off everything except calls,
texts, and calendar. Every notification
is someone else's priority, becoming
your emergency. Your phone should be a
tool, not a tyrant. Try just one of
these today. Watch how different you
feel. The question is, will you take
back control?